one of the director goes have you done
your subtext work
like no what's that ah you see you think
because you wrote it you know everything
but you don't know everything you've
done the writer work you haven't done
the director work you need to do your
subtext work so I took Mr White bringing
Mr orange into the warehouse all by
themselves Mr orange because he's a cop
is saying plea and he's dying please
please please take him to the hospital
Mr White because he doesn't know he's a
cop he's like no no no I can't take you
to the hospital when you actually start
putting pen to paper becomes a different
thing it actually a lot of stuff opened
up that I hadn't thought about before
because subtext is getting Beyond what's
the obvious there so I wrote down what
does Mr White want from this scene more
than anything else in the world what's
Mr orange one from the scene more than
anything else in this world and what do
I as the filmmaker want the audience to
take away from the scene more than
anything else in the world all of a
sudden the more I wrote the more I
realized the movie was the father-son
story and that Mr White was functioning
as Mr orange father